depuis le début de la pandémie de covit
19 il se démène dans ce que l'on
pourrait appeler un marathon quotidien
ces enfants issus de ce village isolé se
déplace en direction d'une montagne
leur objectif capter un signal radio
pour suivre des cours sans accès
internet ni au réseau
ils sont dans l'obligation de marcher
près de 15 kilomètres dans des
conditions souvent difficiles
nos enfants ne peuvent pas apprendre ils
n'apprennent pas il n'y a pas de signal
internet
pas de signal de téléphones portables
nous n'avons rien nous devons marcher
deux à trois heures par jour car les
petits enfants ne marche pas comme les
adultes
pour ces raisons nous n'arrivons pas à
une heure exacte alors que les horaires
sont également donnés dans les stations
à des heures exactes à ce moment là nous
devons calculé à 7h30 ou 8h nous devons
quitter la maison pour arriver sur la
colline notre problème avec les
étudiants et qu'il n'y a pas de
communication à partir du téléphone
portable et pas de réseau à partir de la
radio et d'internet
deux à trois heures de marche afin
d'atteindre les 4000 mètres d'altitude
nécessaire pour capter ces fameux cours
à distance sous la pression de
l'épidémie de coronavirus le
gouvernement péruvien a fermé ses
établissements scolaires le 12 mars dans
la foulée les autorités ont élaboré un
programme diffusé à la télévision
intitulé j'apprends à la maison le
ministère de l'éducation aurait acheté
plus de 840 milles tablette pour
permettre aux élèves venant des régions
rurales le suivre les programmes
scolaires
l'objectif de l'exécutif favoriser
l'accès des cours sur internet
chose impossible dans le village de kata
tirs nourris au début du mois de mai le
chef d'état péruvien entendez miser un
maximum sur les corps à distance il est
absolument clair qu à court et moyen
terme les cours ne se feront pas sur
place mais à distance les étudiants du
primaire et du secondaire supérieur
technique et universitaire devront
suivre des cours à distance au pérou la
crise scolaire n'est pas l'unique
problème du pays l'économie péruvienne
reste paralysée depuis le début
de la pandémie le président a prévenu
que les conséquences pourraient être
très importantes dans les mois à venir